Man muss denen ja schon noch die Gelegenheit geben, über die Hochladefunktion eine aktualisierte Variante ein, das funktioniert.
Naja, also auch das ist natürlich eigentlich auch ziemlich unangenehm.
Es gebietet die Fernseher einfach mal Bescheid zu sagen, wenn man auf so was gestoßen ist und das wirklich so katastrophal ausgefallen ist. Ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen, dass sie sich vorher so hundertprozentig darüber im Klaren waren, was sie da tun. Aber wenn jemand so was sehenden Auges tut, dann muss man doch wissen, dass das einem irgendwann auf den Fuß fällt.
Jetzt habt ihr also angeguckt, habt ihr gesagt, so pass mal auf Leute, wir haben einen Staatstrojaner und in x Stunden gehen wir damit an die Öffentlichkeit. Haben die dann erst mal gesagt, so wir wissen gar nicht wovon ihr redet? Oder wie war die Reaktion?
Naja, es ist ja kein Geheimnis, dass der Staat Rechner infiltriert. Eher geheim war, welche staatlichen Behörden machen das? Wir haben ja eine Menge, wir haben ein Bundeskriminalamt, wir haben die Landeskriminalämter, wir haben ein Bezollkriminalamt, wir haben die Bundespolizei, wir haben natürlich aber auch die Geheimdienste, das heißt BND, aber auch das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz und die ganzen Landesämter für Verfassungsschutz. Es war ja gar nicht klar, zu wem gehört eigentlich dieser Trojaner und wer hat da eigentlich wem welche Amtshilfe gegeben. Also es kam dann auch so eine merkwürdige Situation zustande, dass die ganze politische Sphäre, ob im Bund oder in den Ländern, sich eigentlich sehr uninformiert zeigten und offenbar gar nicht wussten, was in ihren Behörden läuft. Bis heute.
Erstmal das Fingergezeichen, ja bei uns nicht, aber bestimmt da, also keine Ahnung.
Das hat ja eine Weile gedauert, ja. Also eh dann auch der Herrmann, der Landesinnenminister von Bayern, dann rausrückte, ja also das ist jetzt hier erstmal ein Bayerischer Trojaner, sieht so aus, aber irgendwie hatte Zeugkriminalamtball auch die Finger drin, denn die haben dabei geholfen. Also das ist ja alles noch so ein bisschen ungeklärt. Es ist schließlich auch eine politische Forderung von uns, wir wollen jetzt mal endlich die Daten auf dem Tisch haben. Aber nicht immer diese Gewinseln und diese Halbwahrheiten, die man jetzt hört.
Der Daniel hat angerufen, das könnte man übrigens auch machen, 0331-70-97-1-0 ist die Nummer und möchte genau etwas zum politischen Umgang mit dieser Debatte sagen. Hallo Daniel.
Ja hallo. Ja, schön, dass das Thema auch mal zur Politik kommt, nicht, dass ich die Technik uninteressant finde, aber ich finde halt, dass die ganze Diskussion auch in der Öffentlichkeit ist fast schon ein bisschen zu sehr auf den technischen Aspekt beschränkt. Ich meine, als Bürger freue ich mich ja fast schon, dass das so schlecht implementiert wurde.
Wie siehst du das eigentlich? Warum haben die so unglaublich dilettiert, also einmal technisch, aber vor allen Dingen auch jetzt in der politischen Antwort?
Ich bin bei Politikern immer eher der Ansicht, man sollte Böses vermuten, auch wenn Unwissenheit vielleicht deine Erklärung wäre. Aber ich finde es halt entsetzlich vor allen Dingen, jetzt wo es rausgekommen ist, was dieser Trojaner alles konnte. Und wie er dann damit umgegangen wurde. Wir hatten da zwar erstmal eine große Bundestagsdebatte.
Hast du die angeguckt?
Nein, ich musste leider auch Zeit dazu. Aber drinnen hat man hinterher auch gehört, die Opposition hat natürlich ordentlich auf den Tisch geschlagen, aber im Grunde genommen ist dann beim einmal auf den Tisch geschlagen geblieben. Wir haben hier einen Bundesinnenminister, der im Wesentlichen gesagt hat, ja, die Gerichte und wir sprechen hier von einem rechtkräftigen Urteil, das die Staatsregierung in Bayern auch nicht angefochten hat. Ja, die Gerichte haben eine andere Meinung als die Regierung, aber das ist ja egal.
Also du findest, dass ja man ignoriert, was die deutsche Rechtsprechung sagt, aber natürlich auch das Urteil aus Karlsruhe sagt.
Genau, wenn wir einen bundesinnenminister haben, der in der Öffentlichkeit in einem Interview mit der Hochserienzeitung auch noch praktisch sagt, ja im Rechtsbuch durch die Behörden ist doch ganz in Ordnung, das müssen wir halt tun.
Also du findest den politischen Skandal dahinter und destört, dass die anderen gar nicht so richtig darauf eingehen.
Ja, der FDP hat sich nur ganz vereinzelt an der Hochschrittsforderung gehört. Ich glaube, ich habe nur eine oder zwei gehört. FDP gab mir glaube ich eine, aber ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher.
Was ist denn in deiner Meinung nach die Konsequenz? Findest du?
Dass das ein Minister ungestraft lagen kann und da kein Aufschreiwislang ist. Das macht irgendwie nichts Gutes über unsere politische Kultur aus.
Also du findest auch der Ersatz weg?
Auf jeden Fall.
Okay, und würdest du dir aber vorher noch von ihm wünschen, dass er draufklärt?
Vielleicht hat er einfach keine Ahnung, weil ich auch, zumindest aber technisch nebene, durchaus glaube, müssten wir eigentlich jetzt spätestens Konsequenzen ziehen. Wurden ja auch in dem Augenblick gemacht, wo wir gesagt haben, okay, wir setzen das erstmal nicht mehr ein. Weil der ganze Umgang dafür ist eigentlich, mindestens die Innenminister von Bund und Bayern müssten eigentlich weg. Im Grunde genommen eigentlich alle Innenminister von Ländern, die sie eingesetzt haben. Das wäre eine lustige Innenministerkonferenz dann das nächste Mal, die wäre sehr leer.
Weil diesen Einsatzstopp betrifft, da ist er wieder zurückgerudert übrigens. Ja, war sein Bayerischer Amtskollege, der eben schon besagte Herrmann, der hat ja irgendwie diesem Stopp dann nicht zustimmen wollen, das heißt, es gibt keinen bundes- oder landesweiten Stopp dieser Software.
Ja gut, inzwischen haben wir ja auch eine neue Version, das heißt, wenn wir gesagt hätten, wir stoppen den Einsatz, nehmen wir einfach die andere Version, da bin ich auch Informatiker genug, um sowas genau zu verstehen.
Dann würdest du eigentlich finden, dass, mal angenommen, also er kann sich echt nicht halten in diesem Job, findest du das sein Nachfolger oder wie sollte er das angehen in Bezug auf die Transparenz, also was würdest du fordern? Von seinem Nachfolger jetzt?
Vom Nachfolger, das ist natürlich die wichtigste Forderung für zukünftige Einsätze einer, ich sag mal derartigen Software, um das mögliche beizufassen, was ihr auch schon gefordert habt jetzt hier im Radio und auch vorher schon, dass diese Transparenzkriterien erfüllt sein müssen, das heißt, wer muss den einsetzenden Behörden wirklich im Quellcode vorliegen und selbst übersetzen und so weiter und die müssen Leute haben, die das von Verstehen rein technisch gesehen, sodass man zumindest sichergehen kann, dass die Behörden wissen, was sie tun. Nur, ihr habt es jetzt angesprochen, von wegen Nachweisen auf eine Software, das irgendetwas nicht kann, ist schwer bis unmöglich. Von daher sehe ich eigentlich einen verfassungskonformen und rechtmäßigen Einsatz eines Trojaners generell sehr kritisch und gerade wenn es nur um Telekommunikationsüberwachung geht, fragt man mal Skype oder wem auch immer an, die geben einem von den Mitschnitten. Da braucht man halt gar nicht die Computer zu infiltrieren.
Okay, dann müssen wir auf jeden Fall noch mal gucken, ist denn so was wie ein Staatstrojaner überhaupt möglich, um diesem Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil zu entsprechen. Bevor wir dazu kommen, sprechen wir jetzt noch mit Kai. Vielen Dank erst mal Daniel, der eine Frage oder eine Meinung zur Analyse-Darstellung durch den CCC hat. Hallo Kai.
Hallo, ganz grundsätzlich erstmal vielen, vielen Dank für die Arbeit des CCC. Also das kann man gar nicht hoch genug schätzen.
Da freuen wir uns.
Nein, also das ist wirklich Wahnsinn.
Hat auch Spaß gemacht übrigens.
Im Nachhinein betrachtet hätte man gerne mitgemacht, wenn man es gewusst hätte aufeinander.
Du kannst dich noch beteiligen, also die IDDBs liegen da, tue dir keinen Zwang.
Ja, was ich jetzt noch in Anschluss an den Vorredner sagen wollte, bei den Forderungen, die wir stellen müssen, da muss ganz klar sein, dass wir uns nicht in Kleinteiligkeit skaloppieren. Wir müssen ganz klar fordern, Trojaner auf Privatrechnern durch den Staat darf es nicht geben. Schluss, Aus, Ende, Punkt, Final.
Da können wir uns durchaus auch anschließen, so ist nicht.
Nein, also warum, da stellt sich einfach nicht die Frage. Nachher kann ich fast nie nachweisen, bis nie nachweisen, dass da nicht sonst noch was gelaufen ist. Also wenn ich beim Richter hinterlege, Version A auf dem Rechner war, Version B, die Überprüfung in der Forensik geschieht auch durchs LKA. Also im Zweifel zwei, wenn da sich Leute kurzschließen. Also man könnte es nicht ausschließen, Gerichtsfest. Meiner Ansicht nach, dass da nichts gelaufen ist, wo dann die eine Stelle die andere Stelle schützt oder deckt oder wie auch immer.
Ich muss aber sagen, in der Argumentation kriegst du spätestens ein Problem, wenn jetzt jemand kommt und sagt so, naja gut, technisch gesehen magst du Recht haben, aber wenn du das unterstellst, dann unterstellst du den Behörden ja bei jedem Ermittlungsverfahren, dass sie böswillig sind. Das würde dann auch heißen, irgendwie Spuren am Tatort werden gefälscht, Drogen werden untergeschoben. Also das kannst du ja sozusagen in jedem Ermittlungsverfahren an jeden Stellen...
Nee, nee, nee, nicht wirklich. Ein normales Ermittlungsverfahren hat immer, immer erstens, also wenn am Tatort da bin, ist nicht nur ein Polizist oder so, der das in seinem Stimmenkämmerlein macht und der auch die fachliche Kompetenz womöglich dann am Ende hat, das zu tun, sondern da sind mehrere Leute parallel. Und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass alle irgendwie, naja, sagen, Rechtsstaat ist mir egal, ich will meine Verurteilung am Ende sehen, ist relativ gering. Außerdem, wie gesagt, dem einzelnen Polizisten kann man bestimmt vertrauen. Die Gefahr kommt immer dann, wenn sich der Polizist hinter der Behörde verstecken kann und sagen kann, bei euch ja nicht. Ja, oder dem Hersteller in dem Fall. Und das Problem ist, dass so eine Überwachungsmaßnahme, TKÜ, Quellen-TKÜ oder wie es auch immer beschönigt wird, dann genannt wird, das ist ja relativ geheim und verdeckt. Das ist ja keine offene Maßnahme.
Nein, nicht relativ, es ist total geheim und verdeckt. Ja, jetzt im Nachhinein nicht mehr, aber...
Nein, aber ich unterstelle auch mal, dass potenziell nicht alle kriminellen Unbedarf sind technisch und womöglich so was naken können.
Bisher kennen wir keinen Fall, wo der Verdächtige selber bemerkt hatte, während der Ermittlung.
Das ist doch keine Fälle, die vor Gericht kommen.
Aber die, die da bisher gelaufen sind, das war auch alles nichts, was in irgendeiner Form in der Nähe dessen war, was durch das Gerichtsurteil gedeckt worden wäre. Also das waren jetzt keine Fälle, wo es wirklich um erhebliche Rechtsgüter, um irgendwie Schaden...
Eine schwerste Kriminalität oder Gefahren für den Staat.
Das war...
Das ist aber jetzt auch wieder unterscheiden.
Aber das war doch zu erwarten. Allein deshalb schon... Wenn der CCC oder auch sonst Hacker an sich auftreten, da sollten wir uns echt nicht... Also auf die Details sollten wir uns da nicht einlassen. Das machen dann die Politiker nachher schon von selber. Nein, also ganz klar dieses Klein-Klein und dieses Hin- und Hergezerre, ja geht das oder geht das nicht, das machen dann schon die Politiker und die werden es auch schon weit genug verwässern. Da ist es dann, finde ich, besser, wenn sich der CCC mit einer Verstände oder sonst überhaupt die Leute mit technischem Sachverstand mit einer relativ extremen Position in so einem Fall hinstellen und sagen, ja, also...
Das ist jetzt schon eine Extremposition zu fordern, dass ein Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts eingehalten werden muss. Das muss man mal in der Wahrnehmung irgendwie, dass das als Extremposition durchgeht, dass sich Leute, die es schafft, die Urteil halten.
Nein, aus meiner Sicht ist das keine Extremposition. Aber das Problem ist, wenn man dann schon anfängt zu sagen und die Argumentation aufmacht, na ja, wenn es dann eben halbwegs konform wäre zum Urteil, ging es ja wenigstens nicht, dann steigen sie drauf ein. Und dann kommen diese ganzen Sachen, die Herrmann oder wie sie alle heißen gebracht haben. Ja, aber wir haben es ja nur rechtskonform eingesetzt. Das war der genialste Spin, den ich gesehen habe. Und die Presse ist drauf reingefallen. Also in weiten Teilen abzuschreiben und dann nicht kritisch danebenzuschreiben, ja, ihr hättet das ja gar nicht so einsetzen dürfen.
Ja, aber Kai, die Lesekompetenz, die man dann dem Leser zumutet, okay, der hat jetzt so großen Unsinn geredet, das brauchen wir nicht mehr kommentieren, das wird der Leser selbst verstehen.
Das ist die Feferlogik, oder?
Aber sag mal Kai, glaubst du wirklich, dass man den Einsatz eines wie auch immer gearteten Staatsstrojaners verhindern kann in Zukunft?
Also politisch verhindern?
Politisch verhindern kann man den bestimmt nicht, aber man muss klare Regeln aufstellen, dass das nicht geht. Und wenn das nicht geht, dann muss es auch für alle Verantwortlichen klare Strafen geben. Denn zum Beispiel jetzt, was ich überhaupt nicht in der Diskussion gesehen habe, ist irgendwelche Konsequenzen rechtlicher Natur, die für die jeweiligen...
Rechtsbrecher?
Ja, Rechtsbrecher, ob das jetzt der Polizist ist, der kann sich womöglich am Ende noch darauf raustreten, dass er irgendeinen Befehl bekommen hat. Würde ich womöglich sogar noch akzeptieren wollen, der kleine Polizist am Ende der Befehlskette hat womöglich überhaupt nichts zu entscheiden gehabt, was das angeht. Aber spätestens dann auf politischer Ebene, da muss dann irgendwann was kommen. Also wenn es ein Bruch dessen ist, was das Bundesverfassungsgericht ist, das muss hochverrat sein, aber das ist es halt irgendwie nicht.
Na gut, aber hochverrat ist vielleicht ein bisschen doller, oder?
Also Polizisten haben sich im Dienst schon an das Grundgesetz zu halten.
Mir geht es aber eigentlich nicht ums Strafrecht. Also ich würde immer eher denken, dass das eine Frage des politischen Anstandes ist und auch der politischen Kultur. Also ich würde da gar nicht mal mit den Paragrafen reiten wollen. Also da geht es um Verantwortung, die jemand übernimmt, wenn über viele Jahre, und das Urteil ist ja ein bisschen älter, ignoriert wird. Ich bin da schon mit dir, also ich kann das schon verstehen, was du sagst.
Ja, muss man es auch aus der Position der Beamten, die da arbeiten, sehen. Wenn die so ein Tool in die Hand gedrückt bekommen und den Auftrag macht damit mal was, das kann ich mir durchaus unangenehmst vorstellen, sowas dann einsetzen zu müssen, wo eben ganz genau, oder ja, die Frage nicht geklärt ist, kann das mehr, kann ich mich da jetzt in irgendeiner Form mit Strafe machen? Mach ich da jetzt Dinge, die irgendwie nicht korrekt sein sind? Kann ich mich hier überhaupt so verhalten, dass es rechtlich einwandfrei ist?
Die Frage ist, ob ein Beamter in der Stelle überhaupt mitkriegt, was er da macht. Ob er da überhaupt klar kriegt, dass er jetzt nicht eine Software anwendet, die ihm an Frauen spricht, sondern dass da irgendwas anderes passiert.
Wir müssen sehen, die Digitask-Firma ist da hingegangen, hat auch eine ordentliche Produktpresentation gemacht. Also was man ja in der Regel als bedienender Beamte kriegt, ist ja erst mal nur eine Oberfläche, mit der man umgeht.
Der Beamte kriegt diese Software und denkt dann so, alles super. Ist ja abgesegnet und revisionssicher protokolliert.
Oh man, das Schlagwort hatten wir noch gar nicht.
Kai auf jeden Fall erst mal vielen Dank. Er sagt, auf jeden Fall extreme Forderungen sind ganz wichtig und jemand zurücktreten sollte auch. Wir haben jetzt noch, bevor wir zur revisionssicheren Protokollierung kommen, den Peter, der eine Frage hat.
Ich würde gerne direkt an Kai anknüpfen und mich ihm auch nochmal anschließen mit dem Dank an den CCC. Ja, es sind eure Pressemeldungen an Punkt 4 eine Forderung, die ich beim ersten Mal fast überlesen hätte und beim zweiten Mal dachte ich, das ist eigentlich ein sehr genialer Punkt.
Du meinst die Infiltration und Beweissicherheit.
Genau, das meine ich so. Als Informatiker wissen wir erstmal, dass es nicht möglich ist, technisch einen Missbrauch einer Software zu verhindern. Auf der rechtlichen Ebene wissen wir, dass man da zwar viel regeln kann, was aber nicht unter allen Umständen immer eingehalten wird oder eingehalten werden kann. Als ich mich dann mit dem Punkt beschäftigt habe, dachte ich, die uns regierenden Sicherheitsbehörden, laut Herrn Muhl haben wir nicht alle gesagt, wir haben das Ding ja nur regelkonform eingesetzt. Wenn es ein Beweismittelverwertungsverbot gäbe, für sämtliche Daten, die nichts mit der direkten Kommunikation zusammenhängen, dann wäre zumindest in einem Verfahren ja auch kein Missbrauch dieser Daten oder Entgegbrauch dieser Daten mehr möglich. Mich würde dann erstmal interessieren, wer da an Ministern oder irgendwelchen Arztchefs nachher sagen würde, nein, das geht ja nicht, weil. Also wir können diese Beweismittel nicht verbieten, weil. Nur dann kämen sie an dem Punkt ja nicht mehr weiter, weil da keine Argumente mehr vorhanden wären. Mich interessiert jetzt vor allen Dingen, ob man wohl diesen Punkt weiter ausbauen könnte. Constanze ist da ja sehr an der Front, politisch.
An der Front?
An der Front, ja. Das war nämlich, was ich heute auch getwittert hatte, ich hab's auch direkt an ihre Adresse gerichtet und gesagt, das wäre eigentlich ihr Punkt jetzt darauf einzusteigen, zu sagen, da machen wir das Ding doch rechtlich wasserdicht. Dann brauchen wir uns darüber schon mal nicht mehr zu streiten.
Ja, also ich kann mehrere Hinweise geben. Also es gab ja mit der Justizministerin auch Gespräche, nachdem wir es veröffentlicht haben, weil sie ja auch technisch sehr großes Interesse hatte. Also auch erstmal zu erfahren, was da eigentlich wirklich technisch geht. Denn offenbar ist es ja auch für sie als Ministerin über die Behörden nur sehr schwer zu erfahren. Zum anderen würde morgen, also ohne dass sie, ich will nicht Werbung machen, aber eine große Zeitung hat morgen ein längeres Interview mit ihr. Also wo sich zwei Leute, unter anderem ich vom CCC, mit ihr zusammengesetzt haben und nochmal darüber gesprochen haben. Nachdem jetzt einfach ja noch viele ochiöstische Fragen offen sind. Sie ist ja nun mal die Bundesjustizministerin. Also wer den morgen lesen will, dem sei vielleicht, da ist nämlich die Frage der Beweislichkeit auch nochmal angesprochen, zu Lektüre empfohlen. Allerdings, letztlich glaube ich, eine Ministerin hat sicherlich ein gut Gespür dafür, was ist eigentlich wirklich machbar. Und man muss natürlich sehen, welche Extrempositionen sich da letztlich gegenüberstehen. Nämlich die Frage, Leute die sagen, es gibt Kommunikationen, wir müssen die abhören. Das ist ja wirklich so die Friedrich Nummer auch, die im Interview sagt, das Entscheidende ist, wir können abhören, anderen ist es erstmal egal. Und wenn man dann mit solchen Argumenten kommt wie, ja aber was ist denn mit Beweissicherheit, dann gerät man in auch schwierige rechtliche Fragen. Denn auch heute können natürlich unrechtmäßig erlangte Beweise verwendet werden, unter bestimmten Umständen. Es gibt also nicht ein generelles Verbot, der sozusagen, die Engländer sagen Fruit of a Poison Tree, also dass man eben auf dem verbotenen Wege etwas erlangt hat. Man kann das in Deutschland teilweise machen. Und das ist ein schwieriges juristisches Minenfeld. Also empfehle die Lektüre dann morgen. Man merkt ja auch, dass die Justizministerin durchaus ein bisschen rumeiert. Aber aus unserer technischen Sicht ist das eigentlich vollkommen klar. Wir wünschen uns, dass wenn sie infiltrieren, die Beweise davon nicht erlangt werden können. Das hieße aber in der Konsequenz, dass es eine Infiltration überhaupt nur noch für die Online-Gesuchung geben darf. Und dann ja eben unter den besonders...
Für die Quellentickerübe geben darf.
Ja, für die Quellentickerübe. Also aus meiner Sicht müsste die für das Strafverfahren weg. Denn das ist beweislich ja nicht zu erlangen. Also mag ja sein, dass ich da irgendwie zu technisch denke und zu wenig juristisch, aber... Also ich kenne mit der Argumentation, dass man eben, es geht technisch und wir müssen unbedingt abhören, wir müssen überhaupt nichts anfangen, wenn ich mir die technischen Realitäten ansehe und feststelle, eigentlich ist es nicht sicher zu machen, dass man sagen kann, ich habe hier ein beweisfestes, ja zum Beispiel, Datei, die ich eben im Gerichtshofverfahren später auch verwenden kann. Also bei uns haben eben auch Leute, gegen die ermittelt wird, viele Rechte. Und die sollte man dann genauso gut stärken wie die Rechte der Ermittler, die ja sehr viel gestärkt wurden in den letzten Jahren.
Jetzt ist eine Frage, die im Blog aufgetaucht ist auch, wenn man genau bei dieser Diskussion eine Frage stellt, dann sagt man halt sowas und dann sagen andere Leute, ja, aber weißt du eigentlich, ich vertraue dem Staat. Es ist doch gut, dass er die Verbrecher fängt und dann muss er halt auch diese Mittel zu einsetzen. Und das ist schon irgendwie okay. Gibt es da Gegenargumente?
Wir fragen einfach mal Peter, wo er schon da ist. Vertraust du da?
Ich neige immer wieder dazu, bis ich dann an irgendeinem Punkt wieder sehe, dass das Vertrauen vielleicht doch ein Stück zu weit ging. Und gerade dieser Staatstrojaner ist jetzt wieder so ein Punkt. Ich beschäftige mich ja auch schon seit 2007 etwa intensiv mit dem Thema und habe viele Diskussionen geführt an allen möglichen Orten mit allen möglichen Leuten. Und dachte dann, okay, ich mache jetzt irgendwann mal den Punkt. Ich nehme all das, was uns versichert wird von der Politik und nehme das mal als gegeben. Es wird gesagt, in welchen Grenzen es eingesetzt wird. Wir haben zwischendurch gehört, dass es nur ein- oder zweimal überhaupt eingesetzt wurde.
Angeblich, aber nun ganz sicher nicht, stimmt bei dir nun wissen?
Ja, genau so. Und dann kommt der Punkt, wo wir dann plötzlich wieder erfahren, aha, es läuft offensichtlich doch anders. Das heißt, wir sind eigentlich gezwungen, da ständig den Druck aufrechtzuerhalten und ständig zu misstrauen. Wir sind gezwungen zu misstrauen, auch wenn wir vertrauen möchten.
Aber ist es nicht unsere Aufgabe als Bürger, wenn wir nicht scharfer sein sollen, sondern mündige Bürger? Ist es sowieso unsere Aufgabe, denen immer wieder auf die Finger zu gucken?
Das ist in dem Moment, wo wir uns politisch engagieren und aufmerksam sind, natürlich. Nur geht das ja für eine sehr große Masse eben nicht.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, die Unterhaltung, die ihr gerade führt, die ist sozusagen, also Leute, die derselben Meinung sind, bekräftigen sich darüber. Wenn jetzt aber jemand ankommt und sagt, was willst du denn machen gegen die Terroristen oder gegen die bösen Schwerfabriken?
Was sagt man denen dann? Ich interessiere mich nicht für Politik.
Entschuldigung, hier war kein Terrorismus, hier war ein Kaufmann, der Medikamente exportiert und einen Bodybuilder, der mit Anabolika gehandelt hat.
Auch das ist verfliegt gekurnt gekommen, bisher in der Diskussion, dass es nie um Terroristen und schwere Kriminalität ging.
Der Punkt ist halt, man sollte sich nicht einfacher Bürger darum kümmern müssen, dass die Leute da sich gesetzeskonform verhalten.
Da werden wir nicht mehr dran vorbeikommen.
Das ist das Traurige, da sollte es eigentlich Kontrollinstanzen geben, die automatisch das sicherstellen und das scheint da nicht der Fall zu sein.
Hier ist ja noch ein bisschen mehr.
Die LKAs haben sich ja sogar den Einsatz gegenseitig abgenickt und gesagt, die Software ist okay, haben wir uns auch angeguckt. Das war ja sogar eine Forderung, dass das extern noch mal angeschaut werden sollte, wenn so etwas eingesetzt wird. Und extern sah dann für die aus. Ja, das hat aber das LKAs im anderen Bundesland sich für uns angeguckt.
Moment, ich will noch mal einen Aspekt ansprechen, der scheint mir noch mal wichtig. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass hier nur so ein simpler Rechtsbruch passiert ist. Sondern was wir hier blicken, finde ich eigentlich einen größeren Skandal. Ich hatte das vorhin schon mal kurz angedeutet. Das Urteil ist vom Februar 2008, was wirklich viel Zeit ist, die vergangen ist. Und dieses Urteil ist an Klarheit eigentlich nicht missverstehend. Das kann sich jeder ansehen. Wenn die Quellentheke betrifft, ist das eindeutig und klar. Und auch die Unzulässigkeit bestimmter Funktionalitäten, zum Beispiel eben den Update- und Nachladefunktionen, aber natürlich auch die Bildschirmfotos, insbesondere die sind schon längst festgestellt. Es gibt das Urteil Auslandshut, das werden viele jetzt kennen. Es gibt aber auch juristische Literatur. Ich darf zum Beispiel verweisen auf mehrere Texte von Ulf Bührmeier, von Matthias Becker, also angesehener Verfassungsjuristen oder auch jetzt kürzlich von Frank Braun. Es ist ja jetzt schon klar, dass hätte längst eine genaue Regelung geschaffen werden müssen, weil das im Urteil ja drin steht. Und sie nehmen aber einfach den 100a, der Strafprozessordnung, also so eine Art Auffangparagraph für alle möglichen Telekommunikationsüberwachungen. Nach 100a erlaubt die Telekommunikationsüberwachung für sehr, sehr viele Fälle für so einen Straftatenkatalog. Man hätte aber eigentlich eine viel konkretere Lösung finden müssen, denn das steht bereits im Urteil seit Jahren. Deshalb ärgert mich insbesondere diese Ignoranz gegen die Urteile und dass man überhaupt nicht auf die Idee kommt, auch nur einen Mühe hinter dem Urteil zurück zu bleiben und nach so einer Klatsche aus Karlsruhe mal nachzudenken. Okay, wie können wir denn eine balancierte Lösung finden? Wir wollen einen Verbrecher fangen, ja klar, aber wie kann eine Lösung aussehen, die nicht genau diese Verfassungsgrenze aus Karlsruhe umsetzt, sondern einfach überlegt, wo eine sinnvolle Balance sein kann, die nicht immer nur die Sicherheitsbehörden in den Vordergrund schiebt? Und da scheint mir der eigentliche Skandal, den wir uns auch gewöhnt haben.
Das ist tatsächlich sozusagen eine Frage, über die würde ich dann gerne nochmal genau darüber sprechen. Was ich auch in der Diskussion gesehen habe, ist, es geht hier um einen sozusagen Bruch eines Verfassungsgerichtsentscheidens, einer Verfassungsgerichtsentscheidung. Aber eigentlich ist es auch bei den Leuten, die das entdeckt haben und die Leute, die auf der Seite dieser Aktivisten sind, ist eher so, naja, das ist schlimm, aber wir wussten es ja immer. Irgendwie ein bisschen komisch. Eine halbe Stunde haben wir noch hier im Chaos Radio Folge 173, wo es um den Staatstrojaner geht, wo wir schon darüber gesprochen haben, wie der aussieht, was der so kann, warum er das nicht können darf und wie die politische Reaktion darauf ist. Haben wir noch was wichtiges vergessen?
Ja, es gibt noch einen schönen Hinweis, nämlich von Jens Kubizier. Der hat uns im Twitter gerade darauf hingewiesen, dass es eine sehr schöne Darstellung von Heise gibt. Wenn man mal wissen will, also wie eben dieser ECB-Modus bei den Verschlüsselungskies nix sagt, da kann sich mal so eine grafische Darstellung......von dem Algorithmus... Und wer die finden will, der kann einfach in Niblas Twitter-Account klicken oder in Kubizier. Und da findet man diesen Link zu dieser schönen Grafik. Ich finde die sehr gelungen, die zeigt das sehr schön.
Wunderbar, jetzt ist ja im Laufe dieser ganzen Diskussion auch gefordert worden. Ich möchte mal vorgreifen, dass es ein Inter-Minister geben soll.
Meint ihr, das würde was helfen? Ja, heute haben wir ja schon die ganze Zeit gewartet, dass der BDK, der ist ja so eine Art Lobbyverband, kann man schon fast sagen, der Kriminal, sich mal äußert. Jetzt sind die mit dem Reset-Knopf für das Internet, die haben eine tolle Forderung und heute war wieder der Bundesinternetminister, der allerdings schon öfter mal kam. Und wir warten ja noch auf Vorschläge.
Wer das da machen soll.
Ja, es ist ja auch sehr lustig, dass Sie damit den Innenminister in gewisser Weise schon als ledig betrachten. Und dann müssen wir mal einen hinstellen, der was von Internet versteht. Finde ich eigentlich eine interessante Herangehensweise. Aber natürlich hat der BDK gleichzeitig gesagt, natürlich müssen wir Rechner infiltrieren, als sei Gott gegeben.
Das ist natürlich total wichtig. Ich habe noch so ein paar Detailfragen, die...
Herr Uhlsinn, das neue Schlagwort. Wer ist Herr Uhl eigentlich noch mal genauer erklärt, der ist langjähriger Innenexperte und auch ist doch im Innenausschuss und gehört zum Deutschen Bundestag und zur Fraktion der Union.
Es gibt noch ein paar Fragen, die im Laufe der Sendung bei mir hängen geblieben sind. Das eine ist revisionssichere Protokollierung. Es gab ja eine Aktuelle Stunde im Bundestag, da wurde also häufig darüber gesprochen, so okay, wie, liebes BKA, da war irgendwie ein Sprecher vom Innenministerium, wie wird denn festgestellt, ob der Trojaner das kann, was er ist? Und da kam die interessante Vorstellung, okay, da werden Tests im Labor gemacht, man spannt die Software in so eine Art Schraubstock ein und hämmert dann drauf rum. Und da wurde immer revisionssichere Protokollierung gesagt. Und ich hab dann mal auf Twitter gefragt, ob mir einer erklären kann, was das ist, und bekam die Antwort, ich hab Beamtentum studiert und es gibt ein Buch dazu, was du lesen könntest, aber das geht nicht so kurz. Wisst ihr, was das ist, revisionssichere Protokollierung?
Man kann es schon ein bisschen zusammenfassen. Übrigens, also dieser Sprecher im Bundestag, das war der Staatssekretär Ole Schröder, das war nicht irgendein Sprecher. Aber egal. Tatsächlich, in dem Zusammenhang fiel diese revisionssichere Protokollierung ziemlich das erste Mal. Also auch so ein bisschen, dass es in die Öffentlichkeit kam. Was man damit meint, ist revisionssicher im technischen und juristischen Sinne. Das heißt, eine Information wird so aufgezeichnet, zum Beispiel auf einem Medium, was man nur einmal beschreiben kann, oder eben auch tatsächlich ausdrucken geht durchaus, und zwar in einer sicheren Umgebung, sodass man weiß, dass Dritte auf diese Umgebung Software-Hardware-mäßig keinen Zugriff haben. Das nennt man dann revisionssicher. Auch im Sinne von Gerichtsfest könnte man das übersetzen, sodass die ganze Prozedur in der Aufzeichnung Schritt für Schritt nachvorziehbar ist und nicht manipuliert werden kann.
Vor allem im Nachhinein nicht mehr verändert werden kann, also nicht mehr revidiert werden kann, daher revisionssicher.
Das würde aber für den Trojaner-Einsatz bedeuten, das müsste sagen, von Anfang an, also vom ersten Einsatz bis zum Ende passieren. Wenn ich euch richtig verstanden habe, ist das doch aber nicht möglich.
Na, nimm mal, erklärt mal, wie man das macht. Man könnte das theoretisch schon machen, allerdings kann man nicht beweisen, dass man sich in der Zwischenzeit mit diesem Rechner verbunden hat und da Dinge hinterlegt hat. Weil eben, wie wir nachgewiesen haben, dass jederzeit möglich ist, dass man, wenn man das Protokoll kennt, sich mit diesem Rechner verbinden kann und da genau die Dinge tun kann, die auch der Beamte vor seiner Workstation tut. Von daher kann da so viel revisionssicher geschehen auf der Workstation, die der Beamte da vor sich stehen hat. Solange Dritte daran rummanipulieren können und die Software so schlecht ist, dass sich noch nicht mal dagegen geschützt wird, ja, ist das cool aus.
Also sagen, revisionssicher protokolliert kann werden, ist eine Phrase, eine politische Phrase, die eigentlich mit den technischen Realitäten nicht zusammengeht. Ich möchte nochmal, ist irgendwie von dem Sprechzettel in den Mikrofon gekommen.
Ich möchte nochmal kurz fragen, was der Beamte, der an dem Trojaner sitzt, könnte man möglicherweise, sage ich jetzt mal, revisionssicher protokollieren, aber was andere Leute mit derselben Software machen nicht, ist es nicht generell überhaupt ein Problem, wenn man einen Rechner überwacht, dass man gar nicht weiß, ob jetzt die Eingabe, die man da gerade mitliest, von dem Typen kommt, der vor dem Rechner sitzt, oder ob das irgendjemand fernsteuert?
Richtig, darum haben wir ja diesen Fake-Trojaner vorgestellt, der eben irgendwelche Sachen zurückliefert und nicht das, was eingegeben wird. Und da kann natürlich statt einem Foto von Schäuble auf dem Rückkanal ein Fensterinhalt, der unverdächtig ist, zurückgeschickt werden. Also es muss nicht unbedingt nur Katzenbilder zurückkommen, sondern es kann auch was Geschicktes zurückkommen, wo man dann eben nicht weiß, ob das jetzt wirklich echt ist oder nicht echt ist.
Wir haben auch ein bisschen darauf verwiesen, über was wir hier eigentlich reden. Wir müssen ja auch manchmal über Wirtschaftspionage und dergleichen nachdenken. Wir haben ja nur Fälle aus dem Bereich des Zollkriminalamts. Hier muss man auch überlegen, ob eventuelle Konkurrenten Interesse hätten, Daten zu platzieren oder manipulieren. Man kann ja auch jemanden beschuldigen wollen. Und erst recht, wenn man vielleicht über Verfahren redet im Bereich der organisierten Kriminalität, wo man mit ernsthafter Gegenwehr auch technischer zu rechnen hat. Da kann man nicht mit so einem Lulli-Programm kommen, von Dilettanten programmiert. Da muss man sich doch wirklich fragen, gegen wen die da spielen wollen. Wir haben ja auch Fälle jetzt erfahren, fand ich eine unglaubliche Dreistigkeit, wo sie nicht mal geschafft haben, ein Ding zu platzieren und teilweise die Festmatte beschädigt haben. All diese Fälle kommen jetzt aus dem Bundesland zusammen. Und ich bin jetzt schon gespannt, was in den fünf, sechs Wochen, wenn die ganzen Anfragen in den Parlamenten und im Bundestag beantwortet werden müssen, was da noch ans Tageslicht kommt. Ich bin auch immer noch entröstet darüber, dass wir immer noch keinen Innenminister haben im Land und im Bund, der doch mal die Fakten auf den Tisch legt. Jetzt immer dieses Gesag ja, da gibt es vielleicht noch andere Firmen, ja welche denn? Wir wollen sie gerne mal hören. Also irgendwie jetzt alle paar Monate mit neuen Trojanern, die wir analysieren, kommen. Also ich finde, das ist einfach eine Bringschuld der Politik. Die haben die Rechte übertreten. Jetzt finde ich, sind sie den Bürgern auch mal schuldig klar, einen Reintisch zu machen, sowieso den Einsatz zu stoppen und ordentliche gesetzliche Grundlagen zu schaffen, die wir debattieren sollten, allesamt. Und offensichtlich ja auch noch innerhalb der Regierungskoalition, da ist ja wenig Einigkeit.
Statt selbstgefährlich zu sagen, ach das Recht, das wird man ja wohl nochmal übertreten können als Politiker.
Also das finde ich, ist tatsächlich auch eine Forderung, die wir laut und deutlich immer wieder sagen sollten. Jetzt müssen die erstmal sagen. Sie haben eh immer nur zugegeben, was wir quasi beweislicher hatten, weil sie auch nicht mehr abstreiten konnten. Diese Taktik finde ich so...
Aber seid ihr von der Öffentlichkeit selber auch ein bisschen frustriert, weil ihr fordert das immer und die Öffentlichkeit...
Wir sind die Öffentlichkeit von der Politik. Wir sind einfach genauso frustriert, wie die Wähler da draußen, die gerade sehen, dass die Politiker da rumeiern und irgendwie...
Naja, aber darauf wollte ich ja gerade hinaus. Der CCC sagt so, okay, Staatstrojaner. Der CCC sagt dann so, okay Leute, das geht so nicht weiter. Und der CCC sagt, was Konz gerade gesagt hat, ihr müsst jetzt mal die Dinge auf den Tisch legen. Und alle anderen stellen sich in Präzision und sagen so, cool, der CCC kümmert sich drum, das ist schon ganz schön krass, was da passiert ist, aber das läuft schon irgendwie. Also ich an eurer Stelle würde denken, die Aufregung könnte auch mal ein bisschen größer sein oder nicht?
Ich würde das so eigentlich nicht unbedingt bestätigen. Das eine ist, wir haben unglaublich viele Zuschriften bekommen. Also solche, die sich damit jetzt technisch weiter befasst haben, aber natürlich auch eine Menge in aller Richtung politische Zuschriften. Wir haben mit allen Parteien eigentlich Kontakt. Wir waren bei der FDP, wir waren bei den Sozialdemokraten, wir haben mit der Linkspartei gesprochen. Also da gibt es durchaus eine Menge Kontakte und wir werden auch mit der Union reden. Also das heißt, der Bedarf an Informationen in der politischen Sphäre ist groß und der Bedarf an Zustimmung so, der jetzt auf uns einprasset, ist auch enorm. Also wir sehen natürlich auch, dass wir damit irgendwie Leute erreicht haben, auch gerade, weil wir zusammen mit der Frankfurter Allgemeinen Sonntagszeitung gemacht haben, weil wir es jetzt auch ein bisschen übersetzt haben und auch noch aus der englischsprachigen Welt kommt, eine Menge Leute, die uns da helfen wollen, die die Anfragen in allen Landesparlamenten gestellt haben, von ganz verschiedenen Parteien, die auf Abgeordnetenbotsche gefragt haben, die Peter Altmaier zugetwittert haben. Also da heißt der Peter ja Peter Altmaier. Also da gibt es schon eine Menge Protestpotenzial und Empörung und die kommt auch bei uns an. Ich bin da überhaupt nicht, ich habe da keine Angst vor der Zukunft, sondern ich wünsche mir, dass diese Entröstung schlicht politisch genutzt wird. Naja, ich will jetzt nichts über die Piraten sagen. Also ich bin dann gar nicht so pessimistisch, weil ich den Eindruck habe, die Empörung ist echt, die schlägt uns entgegen und da gibt es Leute, die auch sich richtig engagieren. Also ich meine, diese Anfragen in den Parlamenten, die von allen möglichen Fraktionen kommen, die entstehen ja auch erst. Wir müssen die Leute nicht lesen, verstehen. Ich habe Fragenkataloge von 10 bis 50 Fragen, die in den Parlamenten da ankommen. Da will ich erstmal die Antworten hören. Das wird schon nochmal spannend die nächsten Wochen. Wer weiß, man kann auch nie wissen, was wir noch so haben.
Okay, also sagen, aber ich hatte jetzt eher spekuliert in Richtung Demonstrationen und wie man auf die Straße geht.
Ja, ich hätte nüscht dagegen. Also wir haben ja schließlich auch noch dieses große Pferd, diese zwei Meter Pferde, die wir durch die Gegend ziehen können.
Das könnte man doch nochmal einsehen. Ich finde es auch keine schlechte Idee. Ich habe jetzt nochmal eine kleine Detailfrage, die zum Anfang der Geschichte geht. Ihr habt ja gerade gesagt, dass es noch eigentlich keinen Betroffenen gab, der während der Überwachung mitgekriegt habe, das überwacht wurde. An welchem Punkt ist den Leuten eigentlich aufgefallen, dass sie möglicherweise einen Staatstrojaner auf der Festplatte haben oder hatten?
Na ja, die Fälle, die wir kennen, da war es relativ simpel. Man kriegt die Akten, und dann wird das Verfahren eröffnet und man findet Screenshots.
Das ist also während der Kriegsverhandlung schon?
Nein, nein, damit das Verfahren eröffnet ist, man muss ja nicht schon vor Gericht stehen, damit eben andere Einsichten die Akten nehmen können. Das kann natürlich früher sein. Also man entdeckt einfach Dinge, die man eigentlich so nicht haben könnte. Es gibt noch andere Wege, wie man an eine Form von Screenshots kommt. Also technisch gibt es auch andere Wege. Aber hier hatte der Anwalt, der auch noch, also der Strafverteidiger, der auch noch recht jung war, und jetzt sozusagen nicht technikfern, aber schon eine gewisse Peilung hat von Technik, auch gleich ein Verdacht. Also ich denke, ein guter Strafverteidiger würde das wahrscheinlich sehr schnell überblicken.
Okay, aber das ist der Punkt, dass man schon die Ergebnisse vorlegt und weiß dann, okay, da war möglicherweise irgendwas.
Naja, letztlich, man könnte natürlich auch verbergen. Wenn man es ja in die Akten nicht aufnehmen würde, würde man es nicht unbedingt erfahren. Die Maßnahme bleibt ja heimlich. Also wenn man jetzt nicht einen Trojaner selber entdeckt und in den Akten nichts findet, kann man es natürlich letztlich auch nicht wissen. Also, natürlich außer für den Trojaner, den wir jetzt haben, der wird ja von dem Virus genauer erkannt.
Ich muss auch dazu sagen, dass in einem Verfahren zumindest da auch schon Screenshots aufgetaucht sind, die vor dem richterlichen Beschluss oder der Bestätigung, dass das durchgeführt werden darf, erstellt wurden. Da vielleicht nochmal ein paar Worte zum Richtervorbehalt. Das ist eine Maßnahme, wo eben vorher ein Richter sagen muss, ja, das darf durchgeführt werden. Und ja, da dürfte eigentlich vorher das schon gar nicht eingesetzt wurden. Das wurde da so leger im Nachhinein mal eben als Legitimierung. Eigentlich wurden da Dinge vor Gericht eingebracht, wo eben noch nicht mal ein Richter vorher gesagt hat, das ist okay.
Das ist so wie in der amerikanischen Polizeiseite. Der Polizist tritt die Tür ein und sagt, Hausversuchungsbefehl besorgen wir uns morgen.
Nein, also sowas gibt es im deutschen Recht auch offiziell. Den nennt man Gefahr im Verzug. Also es gibt natürlich Sachen, da kann man diese Richtergenehmigung im Nachhinein einholen, wenn man eben konkreten, ja, fährwiegenden Gefahren entgegenwirken will. Wenn man jetzt an die Quellentickerühe oder an eine Online-Durchsuchung denkt, das ist ja nichts, was sofort passieren kann, sondern hat ja einen gewissen Vorlauf. Man muss ja erstmal ausspionieren, was ist das für ein Rechner? In der Regel muss man auch, es ist ja eine Maßnahme, die ganz am Ende passiert. Da hat man ja schon sowieso alle E-Mails, alle Internetüberwachung, da hat man schon Festnetzelefon, da hat man alle Handyschen abgehört und muss natürlich auch nur einige wissen über denjenigen, den man dort abhört. Insofern ist es ja nicht unbedingt eine Sofortmaßnahme. Aber schon verpflichtend mit diesem Richtervorbehalt. Und da ist natürlich uns auch die Frage, gerade wenn man da technisch drauf guckt, wie kann der eigentlich wissen...
Wie kann ein Richter das beurteilen? Wie kann ein Richter sagen, okay, das ist eine Maßnahme, und dann sage ich ja, das ist eine Maßnahme, und dann sage ich nein. Und das war für mich so das, wo ich am meisten in den letzten Wochen gelernt habe, wie sowas abläuft von den Prozessen her. Die gucken sich das nicht groß an, weil der Aufwand, sowas abzulehnen, wesentlich höher ist, und da macht man sich deutlich unbeliebter, als wenn man sowas durchwinkt. Also ein Richter hat wesentlich weniger Aufwand, damit da überall sein Okay drunter zu setzen, weil die Staatsanwaltschaft, die wird schon nur Dinge einreichen, die jetzt irgendwie Hand und Fuß haben. Man kennt sich da ja auch, und das ist ja dann ein Umgang, der vertrauter ist. Und das ist für die Ungleich aufwendiger, sowas abzulehnen, und das macht man sich natürlich auch sehr unbeliebt.
Der Richter kann unterschreiben und sagen, ja, das findet statt, und wenn er nein sagt, muss er es begründen?
Genau.
Also es ist schon tatsächlich ein strukturelles Problem. Und die Forderung danach, das umzudrehen, die ist sehr alt, zu sagen, also wenn der Richter ablehnt, dann kann er es einfach durchwinken, und wenn er es annimmt, dann muss er es begründen. Aber hier gibt es natürlich Widerstände, die auch politischer Natur sind, die sehr verständlich sind. Bei uns ist es ja dann eine Sache, die letztlich in den Ländern zu finanzieren wäre. Denn man bräuchte dafür mehr Richter. Man muss sich überlegen, wie viele Hundert am Tag von verschiedenen Anordnungen Richter, Ermittlungsrichter unterschreiben. Und natürlich müsste man für mehr Leute sorgen, wenn die sich mehr Zeit nehmen und mehr prüfen.
Das würde unterstrich bedeuten, dass sie sich das dann auch wirklich angucken müssen.
Und was sollen sie sich hier eigentlich angucken? Die Produktpräsentation von Digitas? Also das ist ja auch nochmal ein ganz faktisches Problem. Soll man ernsthaft erwarten, dass sich ein Ermittlungsrichter mit dem Quellenkod ausbaut?
Das heißt jetzt nicht, sondern ich dachte sagen, wenn, dann gibt es dieses Instrument. Irgendwie eine Richter muss nur über den Einsatz entscheiden.
Ja, aber er muss schon vertrauen, dass die Firma oder auch letztlich die Firma, die es herstellt oder die es im Auftrag herstellt, ihm da die Wahrheit sagt. Muss man schon voraussetzen können und zum Beispiel auch keine schlimmen Fehler einbaut. Das kann er ja nicht wissen. Letztlich, wenn er es nur hört, da gibt es ein Produkt, das hat diese und jene Funktionalitäten. Also da hat er ja faktisch wenig Möglichkeiten. Dass natürlich der Ermittlungsrichter im Fall von dem Landshut, also sozusagen unser erster Trojaner, nicht von vornherein kritisch war, ist natürlich schon zu hinterfragen. Denn hier war ja eine Software im Einsatz, die eben nicht nur die Skype abhören konnte, sondern eben auch die Bildschirmfotos gemacht hat. Das wurde ja erst im Nachhinein für rechtswidrig erklärt. Da muss man sich schon fragen, wo war denn da eigentlich die rechtliche Vorprüfung?
Jetzt in der Diskussion kommt ja immer wieder auch die Forderung auf. Das klingt dann immer so, als ob das die Lösung wäre. Na ja, in Zukunft wird der Staatstrojaner einfach von offiziellen Stellen dann programmiert. Dann kann er richtig auch darauf vertrauen.
Mit den Leuten von Digitas und Abwehr?
Weiß ich nicht, wer das dann machen soll, aber es ist auch Quatsch, oder?
Es ist ein Vorschlag, den man natürlich mal debattieren kann. Aber letztlich ist es nur dann ein Vorschlag, wenn man die Probleme, die sich jenseits davon stellen, auch mitlöst. Wenn man meint, man hat genug Know-how, dann muss man natürlich in Erwägung ziehen. Aber da gibt es eine Behörde, die viel Know-how darin hat. Das ist das Bundesamt für Sicherheiten der Informationstechnik. Und ich würde sehr hoffen, dass die dafür nicht zum Einsatz kommt. Eine Behörde, die sehr viel über Spionagestoftware und Mailware weiß und auch wie man seine Rechner dagegen nutzt, die gibt es damit, mit diesem BSI. Aber die wäre natürlich sehr schlecht beraten, wenn sie jetzt den Spagat versucht, auf einer Seite selber die Spionagestoftware zu bauen, aber auf der anderen Seite die Bürger und Firmen beraten, wie sie sich vor dieser Spionagestoftware schützen.
Vor dieser dann vielleicht nichts, aber vor allen anderen.
Ja, schon, aber das ist von der Glaubwürdigkeit her sehr schwierig, da zu stehen.
Gut, jetzt können wir natürlich sagen, wir bilden das urische Kompetenzzentrum. Anderen nennen sie ja die Überwachungszentrale oder so. Keine Ahnung, da muss man sich schon mal fragen, wen stellen sie da ein. Aber tendenziell hätte ich keine Einwendung, wenn der Staat so etwas entwickelt. Aber dennoch müssen alle Probleme gelöst werden. Und nicht nur die Frage, ob die Firma dann ein Geschäftsgeheimnis haben darf und den Quellcode nicht ausrückt.
Aber habe ich zu verpasst, war nicht irgendwann mitten in der Sendung die Forderung, es soll gar keinen Staat zu ernergeben?
Na ja, aus meiner Sicht wäre das eine gute Forderung. Also ich denke, man sollte... Ja, für alle Überwachungsmaßnahmen muss man sich immer überlegen, ist es verhältnismäßig und zwar im engeren oder weiteren Sinne. Das heißt, gibt es mildere Mittel, die man einsetzen kann? Und ein milderes Mittel als die Infiltration eines Rechners ist das Abhören beim Anbieter. Warum man diesen Weg dann nicht auch beschreiten will, das stellt sich mir schon als Frage. Nur, weil was technisch geht. Genen tut noch viel mehr.
Aber dann hätte man dieses Problem spätestens dann wieder, wenn tatsächlich gute Verschlüsselung für audio funktioniert.
Möchtest du die Verschlüsselung der Besitz zu sagen, Verschlüsselungsverfahren, die sicher sind?
Nein, aber dann geht es irgendwann nicht mehr, dass man beim Anbieter abhören kann.
Dann hätte man diese Diskussion wieder.
Aber in dem Moment, wo du ein Gerät einsetzt, was eine ordentliche Verschlüsselung hat, dann setzt du auch ein Gerät ein, was gegen so etwas wie eine Trojaner Installation gesichert ist. Das ist ja nicht so, als könnte man so Geräte nicht bauen, als würden so Geräte nicht gebaut und als würden so Geräte nicht eingesetzt. Also letztendlich ist die Lücke oder der Horizont, in dem so eine Software eingesetzt werden kann, so unendlich klein, wenn man es wirklich rechtlich konform macht. Und die anderen Mittel, die man da zur Verfügung hat, so mannigfaltig vorhanden, als dass sich das nicht, allein auch für die Ausgabe mehrere Millionen auf so ein Produkt zu werfen, das überhaupt nicht in einer Relation steht zu den Möglichkeiten, die man sonst noch ausschöpfen könnte.
Also es ist natürlich eine Debatte, die wir in Zukunft immer haben werden. Das ist, glaube ich, keine Sache, die wir nur in diesem Monat debattieren oder in diesem Jahr. Denn die Problematik wird sich stellen. Wir brauchen für eine ordentlich funktionierende IT heutzutage, egal ob privat oder wirtschaftlich, brauchen wir eine funktionierende Kopptographie. Einfach schlicht treiben sich genug normale Kriminelle rum, die irgendwie Spionage-Software benutzen. Und da muss man Lösungen finden, das sehe ich schon.
Also allein Wirtschaftsspionage, das ist ja gerade in Deutschland wichtig, wo wir von Innovationen abhängig sind, dass Firmen forschen, dass Firmen wirklich Geheimnisse haben und diese auch geschäftlich nutzen.
Wenn man dann immer die Argumentation hört, der Staat muss da irgendwie auf Augenhöhe agieren, ich finde halt, dass er das nicht muss. Denn er ist eben kein Krimineller, sondern er ist erstmal ein Staat, der sich an Regeln hält. Und ob zu den Regeln gehören muss, in die quasi Gehirne von Menschen einzudringen, nur weil sie jetzt die Möglichkeit haben, das wird sie so denken, aufzuschreiben, auch wenn den Rechner nie verlässt. Ich finde, das ist eine grundsätzliche Frage, die auch wirklich aus meiner Sicht eine Wertedebatte ist, inwieweit wir dazulassen wollen. Und ich neige da nicht dazu, das sofort entscheiden zu wollen für alle Zukunft, aber schon gar nicht immer nur dem Wünschen und Wollen von der Mittler zu folgen.
Jetzt ist die Sendung bald zu Ende. Wir haben den Trojaner ausführlich auseinandergenommen. Über Twitter kam gerade noch die Frage rein, ob ihr eine Prognose habt, ob und wann der Herr Friedrich zurücktreten wird?
Die muss ich lieber machen. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob der Skandal so lange auch über Vorgaben aus Karlsruhe hinweg gesehen zu haben und das ja eigentlich auch in Zukunft fortführen zu wollen. Das ist ja eine Sache, die er würde fortführen. Da gibt es ja nicht mal so einen Moment Stillstand und Nachdenken. Ich weiß nicht, ob das genügen wird.
Da fehlt auch immer die Selbsterkenntnis, also wirklich die festzustellen, dass man da Unrecht getan hat, dass man sich gegen ein Grundgesetz offen ausgesprochen hat. Die Scham fehlt da.
Politische Scham, ja. Aber nicht nur bei Herrn Friedrichs, sondern bei der gesamten politischen Kaste, möchte ich es mal nennen.
Nein, ich würde keine generelle Politikerbeschimpfung loslassen.
Der Innenminister, wenn er zurücktritt, das könnte er entweder machen, weil er selber sagt, okay, das war schlimm, ich muss zurücktreten, oder er könnte das machen, wenn genug Druck im Umfeld entsteht. Und zumindest dieses Umfeld hat nicht genug Scham, um diesen Druck zu erzeugen.
Oder eben eine offensichtliche Lüge. Manche brauchen länger bei Gutenberg, wenn sie offensichtliche Lügen geben, dann zurücktreten, aber in der Regel ist eine offensichtliche Lüge auch nochmal ein Grund. Das wäre eine Möglichkeit. Aber am liebsten hätte man natürlich einen Anständigen.
Ein Anständigen Politiker meinste?
Ich bin nicht so ein Freund von allgemeiner Politikerstellte. Man sollte schon den Einzelfall betrachten. So wie bei Hackern auch.
Beurteile einen Politiker nie nach dem, was er sagt, sondern nach seinem Jurist.
Oder wie er abstimmt.
Okay, also vielen Dank fürs hier sein, fürs Auseinander in den Straatstrojanern. Constanze Kurz und Libla vom Chaos Computer Club in der Folge 73 des Chaosradios über besagten Staatstrojaner. Gibt es sonst noch Dinge vom CCC, die man wissen sollte, die jetzt anstehen?
Ja, wir haben bald wieder ein Kongress.
Nein!
Ja, zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr. Nein! Es geht jetzt gerade so los, dass das Programm festgezogt wird. Und wir können jetzt schon versprechen, dass es ein sehr spannendes Programm wird.
Gibt es Programme? Wo wird es stattfinden?
Wir sind wie immer am Alex, vier Tage lang im BCC, also im Berliner Kongresszentrum. Und wir freuen uns natürlich, wenn bald die Ticket…
Wollte gerade sagen, wann jetzt los? Weiß man schon, wann es losgeht?
Nein, steht noch nicht ganz fest, aber es wird wieder einen Vorverkauf geben. Denn wir wollen natürlich nicht, dass da jemand in der Kälte anstehen muss. Wir versuchen es doch so zu organisieren, dass es da keinen Stress gibt.
Alles klar. Wir werden mal schauen, ob das funktioniert. Im nächsten Monat gibt es dann nochmal ein Chaosradio, das letzte für dieses Jahr.
Wir haben doch schon eine Themenidee, wir verraten aber noch nichts.
Geheimnisvoll, einen ganzen Monat vorher sogar schon. Wie konnte das passieren? Wir werden mal gucken, ob das klappt. Mir bleibt dann in diesem Fall nur noch eins zu sagen. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und macht immer schön eure Backups.
Don't forget I'm in your extended network, Biax, XO2000.